uh if you send it to zany and you guys
will get you that uh
cbd out guys we'll get you the cbd out
i'm here i can give you this we ain't
playing marbles no more kids
now we're playing let me get back
[ __ ] kev
do i need these headphones no no no uh
no because unless you want to hear i
i've been putting it on the loudspeaker
but i put the headphones on because we
were going to play fall guys
gotcha unless uh kids i just had a very
exciting meeting
um which i can't tell you about right
now but
it was very cool um uh when you're in
the kevin smith business
as me and mr jason muzar
sometimes i'm in the jason news business
um
uh sometimes exciting things happens
where you're like oh
like the movies pop up which has been
happening which is lovely
was a nice surprise kind of come out of
nowhere and then we just had a meeting
me and uh jordan um that was also like
what um so i look forward to being able
to share
that with you ain't gonna happen till
next year but it's gonna be a cool thing
uh okay
lawless182 says was victor garber in the
meeting
sadly no for those of you who are like
what uh uh i'm i'm a big victor garber
fan and one time i tried to get him on
to my podcast to interview him
when he was in argo i was like oh my god
and i've long been a fan of the guy's
work
going back to god's spell going back to
sweeney todd going back to his broadway
stuff
and um he uh said no his people were
like oh no
he's busy or something like that and so
i wrote back i was like oh i can wait
man like when's available when he's
available like it's no rush
his time and they wrote back like that's
not going to happen
and like made it clear that like he
don't want to talk to you so i don't
think victor garber likes me very much
and um i you know we talked about it on
fat man beyond me and mark bernardin
about like maybe like trying to get him
on the show
and mark was like well wouldn't it be
funny if i tried to get him and he said
yes to me but no to you
so anyway it's a long way of explaining
that comment um
uh awake saxon says tusk two
i'm shocked we got away with tusk one
but i'll be honest with you i do have a
story for tusk
tusk two um i mean it's not much of a
story here i'll share it with you and
you'll see if you guys like it um
you know mike the great michael parks
who played uh
you know um howard howe the guy who
turns
wallace into a walrus sadly passed away
a couple years ago
an amazing actor that i got to work with
twice once in red state once in
in uh tusk and both times were
highlights of my
whole film career working with parks so
you know parks is gone
he played our quasi-bad guy
quasi-villain
quasi-psychotic um but
you know and and and the ending of tusk
like
you know i if i wanted to be a
commercial filmmaker which apparently
i've never wanted to be
um i would have ended the movie when
you know gila point comes in and raises
his shotgun and then you just
you know hear the walrus like and we cut
to black
i should have just rolled credits that
would have been creepy but
since tusk was born on a podcast that i
did with scott moser spodcast episode
259 the walrus and the carpenter
one of my favorite aspects of that that
podcast
the episode we did was like the
aftermath where like moser uh
you could hear in the end credits of
tusk where we're talking smoking
crafting
about how like they show up and give
them a fish there's a fish wrapped in
paper
so like you know i was pock committed to
that ending from the moment because i
just
moment we started talking about because
i loved it but in retrospect
probably would have been smarter to just
end it
you know cut to black you hear the
walrus scream and then credits and [ __ ]
but nobody's ever accused me of being a
smart man so in any event that's how
tusk ends it ends the way it ends
uh in the small zoo where wallace is
doomed to live out his life
but there's a version of tusk too that
you do
where justin well not justin justin long
is the actor who played the character
wallace
you know you cut to the present and
somebody else gets sucked into the
spider's web a house
come hear stories and when you get to
the house
the new howard howe is wallace
who has gotten out of you know the
walrus trappings and stuff
uh you know is obviously disturbed by
his entire ordeal
and is now like doing it to others
that's what happens you know crime is
visited upon somebody sometimes they
pass that crime on
so there's a way to do a task too where
justin
becomes michael parks's character
where you know wallace becomes a sort of
the new howard howe and you know he's
just doing this walrus thing to somebody
else
so yeah that's possible task two is
possible obviously i [ __ ] thought
about it
um because that just didn't roll off the
top of my head so
it's possible um hey kev
ooh there's a good question about dog
muse
um oh man i missed it he said are we
gonna get dog am i ever gonna get dogma
back i don't know i hope so
uh kev damn it how do you stop this dude
how do you
yeah like make it stop i won't be able
to reach it there you go
yeah just up and down with the wheel i
was doing that but it was something you
got to do first which you only
you knew how to do uh
let's see the one i missed was up here
says uh church 1122. hey kev
when will you get the rights to dogma
back so you can finally get it
get it on digital excellent question uh
i will never get those rights back
i don't own that movie um i will get the
rights to clerks back
in about 10 years 10 12 years in england
um i'll own it again in england i'll
never own clerks again in the united
states
um i don't own any of my movies they're
all owned by somebody else who paid for
him and stuff so
dogma was owned by miramax but then uh
clench your [ __ ] because here comes
the name nobody wants to hear
harvey weinstein personally bought it
away from miramax back when disney owned
miramax and they were like we don't want
this movie to be part of the miramax
family
so harvey bought it personally and he
released it and stuff so harvey
weinstein
currently owns personally currently owns
dogma and as i don't know if anyone's
been following the papers but
harvey weinstein is incarcerated so uh
we reached out a long time ago about the
possibility of
somehow getting it back securing it
buying the movie back or what have you
um so you know fingers crossed one day
that winds up happening but right now
no it's trapped in some other place um
you know a lot of people like it's
always so much on
on uh home video you know like you can
only find it on like ebay for like two
grand
uh is that right not two grand i don't
know what i'm talking about 200 bucks or
whatever
uh but i i say watch it for free on
youtube that's what i do
also if you're a member of that kevin
smith club go to thatkevinsmithclub.com
you might be able to find a very similar
movie in the smithsonian screening room
um okay sean
sean f o'neal says kevin thanks for
saving my life
made me vote go vegan too when i almost
died with 100 blocked
lad thank you well done i got that from
my kid she was like go vegan go
plant-based
and it really made the difference so
i'm with you on that um
uh crop balls crop kraut balls
love it says uh j muse and kevin smith
when
can we see you back on joe rogan's
podcast
your his talks are the best thank you uh
i love going on rogan i've done rogan
what four or five times now
um the last chime you haven't well
you've never done it no he's
you gotta have [ __ ] to talk about you
can't just be like nine
snoochies he's like get the [ __ ] out um
i know ufc sir i could talk to him about
that you could you could actually
um i hope i don't know i don't know if
i'll be getting into sam
see him before he heads off to uh to
texas he's leaving
california you know he's been out here
the whole time but now he's going to
texas built a brand new studio he's got
that
spotify [ __ ] billion dollars and
stuff so i would love to
see him before he goes and stuff because
after this it gets a little more
difficult to get on a show you have to
go out to
texas i'd imagine and stuff but i
honestly like i just don't have that
much to talk about
like last time i saw him was right
before or while we were doing the tour
so you know there was a bunch to talk
about but nothing's really happened
since then and stuff but that being said
you don't really need anything to talk
about when you go into joe rogan he
he can keep that conversation going
without you and stuff so um
yeah i i should i would like to i'm
saying i should as if like
i'm even allowed to but i would like to
go in before he takes off to texas but
if not i'll see him in texas sooner or
later
um you know i'm very delighted
that the world has caught on to joe
rogan um
but as an early adopter um i've always
thought he was just such a [ __ ]
interesting dude
so easy to talk to could talk about
[ __ ] anything and he was in one of my
favorite sitcoms of all time he was in
uh news radio
so i you know i love that the whole
world's like [ __ ] joe rogan and i'm
like welcome to the [ __ ] club man
um he's he's good dude so yeah i i would
like to be on the show again before he
leaves i don't know if it's gonna happen
hackman minnesota says
what's the chance of maulrat's sequel
shot at the mall of america in minnesota
probably minimal that's an operational
mall that's up and running we didn't
shoot at the mall of america and
minnesota we shot in the eden prairie
mall
in eden prairie minnesota which is about
30 minutes 20 minutes down the road from
mall of america
so the question should be more like are
you going to go back to that mall to
shoot the original mall and the answer
i mean if they have a sweet enough like
discount rebate
bonus like when you go shoot at a place
you get this rebate money where you know
the movie isn't cost as much as it did
because you spent money in that state
and they give you a tax
incentive rebate then absolutely um that
would be that's how we wound up in
minnesota in the first place
it was an inexpensive state to shoot of
course i wanted to shoot in new jersey
because
you know clerks were set in new jersey
but we went with minnesota because a
uh you know there was a rebate or a tax
incentive in the state
and b they had uh a big old mall that
was like
at less than 50 capacity the eden
prairie mall
and so that's that's where we went but i
think that mall is up and running in a
good way now
like i've been to that mall they're
actually doing fairly well i mean not
recently obviously i haven't been to the
mall it's been a minute
uh all right let's see let's see what
kids want to know
we're gonna see affleck and mall rats
too he's
written in there shannon hamilton's in
there and uh the actual guy
told me that he's into it so
fingers crossed looking good uh daft
wooly says why do people hate on yogozi
i love that movie
pretentious frog oh my god that was
[ __ ] from the movie i forgot
pretentious frog call of duty
who asked last ink says jake
do you play call of duty war zone yes
sir on thursdays
usually there's your answer
he he likes to keep it short yes keeps
it cl plays it close to the vest
to the chest or whatever um let's see
man
uh teeth leech says you look absolutely
great so glad
that night was not the last time we had
you on the planet
oh the heart attack night me too thank
you plus i missed talking with you at
san diego comic con
it's been about 15 years last time i got
to talk to either of you or jay in
person are you serious
we go every year yeah um if you ever
want to see me i mean i was going to say
come to the imd boat but we didn't do
that this year
uh hopefully next year when we all get
to go to comic con again and think about
what an amazing comic con that's going
to be
after we've all been kept away from it
for a [ __ ] year oh my god it's gonna
be like they discovered the cure for
venereal diseases
everyone's gonna go [ __ ] wild and
just be like ah
it's gonna be crazy fun um but yeah look
for us when we're there for sure man
i'm always around or the stream is the
way
cause here hype trains [ __ ] like that
yeah uh kaiju tyler excellent name
clerk's taught me that anything is
possible if you're passionate enough
thank you then you
then you then you heard the unintended
lesson that we were trying to teach
that's an invaluable lesson i've learned
love you to death man right back at you
um should i turn you back to your thing
and get to my uh
zero zero devil foo or devilu says
thoughts on the snyder cut of justice
league can't wait
can't wait did you see that picture of
steppenwolf i read today
i think grace randolph was talking about
da'sod
is in the cut in the snyder cut we're
going to see da'sod we're going to see
steppenwolf reporting to da'sod
for dc fans of uh jack kirby's work
and and uh the new gods and the fourth
world and all that stuff that's
[ __ ] dope i mean we know we're
getting dark side and that's [ __ ]
cool enough but the
fact that we're getting more of the of
the apocalypse
the world of apocalypse that's really
really cool um i'm just happy for him
that he gets to make the movie he wanted
to make
you know the movie went away from him
under very sad circumstances
and then you know they had to finish a
movie and they finished a movie and it's
not what he had intended so
it's very rare people get a second bite
the apples so lovely that he gets to
make the movie
he wants to make and look he could put
asses in seats you see how many people
wanted the snyder cut so it's not like
they're doing the dude a favor i think
it's like
vice versa i think he's doing them a
favor by doing that movie
um
can i try playing fall guys what is it
uh it's a game
morty 303 says jay thanks for saving my
life my issue was massive addictions
rather than heart blockage
and your early sobriety story gave me
the strength
to finally kick those chemicals seven
year birthday on halloween [ __ ]
meeting you at the elsinore in salem
really made my decade
well done thank you the impact you made
on [ __ ] morty man meanwhile i met
rick
nang nang um
jax dagger says when are you going to
direct a dc movie never they'll never
give me that kind of control man of
a movie i don't even talk about control
like i got to control it
smart money doesn't hand me that kind of
budget and say go make a movie
um i'm not a visionary like that um
they got people that are way better to
do that [ __ ] than me i'm the guy you
want commenting on that movie
keith of these will any of the end
credit scenes from all rats be addressed
in the sequel
yes as a matter of fact what a great
question um they will be
um yes i don't want to say anything more
but yes
everything comes into play everything's
in play in the mall red sequel
um cat cv 1986 says hey
what does a heart attack feel like for
reals
lol uh what a great question mine was
not painful i can't speak for every
heart attack but mine
was no i was not in pain i couldn't
catch my breath that's how it manifested
what i found out when i went to the
hospital was because i had blockage in
the lad it's a big fat artery it goes
across my big fat heart
everyone's got the lad i had 100
blockage in it that's what creates the
particular heart attack i was having
which is called the widow maker
because in 80 of the cases of 100
blockage like i had the patient
always dies so you'd imagine that would
sound painful
but it manifested itself as me not being
able to quite catch my breath
i could go up but not all the way
couldn't ring the bell so i was like
shallow breaths i couldn't be like i
couldn't get a sigh going or anything
like that and so i thought it was a
respiratory problem i thought i was
having some sort of lung thing i thought
oh i smoked too much weed
what we found out when i went to the
emergency room and the doctor
jammed uh you know a camera up my
femoral artery to get to my [ __ ]
heart
the hundred percent blockage in the led
was blowing it up imagine you take a
hose
and you fold it over and it starts
blowing up with water and pressure
on the other side since it was inflating
and blowing up it was pressing down on
my heart
and my heart in turn was pressing down
on my lungs
which prevented me from catching a good
breath
so what i was reading is like oh i can't
catch my breath
was literally a heart attack and so you
know if i'd been
by myself and you know left to my own
devices
i would have just like well maybe i
should just lay down and go to sleep or
something like that until i feel better
and i would have died so thankfully
jason's wife
jordan uh called an ambulance even
though i was like don't
you know don't tell anybody she called
an ambulance when she told me he's like
i called an ambulance i was like what
why would you do that i just smoked too
much weed
if she hadn't called that ambulance and
i hadn't gone to the hospital
i would not be here he'd be doing a
stream about like remember silent bill
what a what a good friend send me your
bits and money thankfully uh
jordan uh saved my life so it was
i didn't feel pain that's why i would
have died because i wasn't
in physical distress where i'm like
elizabeth you know like fred sanford
dying
it was literally just like can't quite
catch my breath and i would have written
it off self-diagnosed as like oh i
smoked too much weed man that's silly of
me
and went to bed and just [ __ ] dropped
dead so um
it wasn't painful now i've heard you
know people have painful heart attacks
we're like
you know and doubled over and stuff mine
wasn't and mine was kind of a silent
killer like that
i would have rather had a painful heart
attack because i would have known
what the [ __ ] was going on i had been
like i am in distress
but as it just read is like i can't
catch my breath
that's the kind of heart attack you
don't think about and then you drop dead
my whole life
you'd hear about relatives like they
just doubled over had a heart attack and
died not always be like how do you not
know
how do you not feel something like that
coming well i didn't feel it coming at
all i was in the middle of it
and i didn't feel it we went it wasn't
until i was in the emergency room
and the doctor goes how do you feel
scale of uh one to ten at what's your
pain level
and i was like negative three and he
goes uh then you're doing it wrong
that's doing what wrong he goes you're
having a heart attack wrong he's going
when you have a heart attack you're
supposed to be in a lot of pain and i
was like
i'm having a heart attack he goes yeah
right now they didn't tell you i said no
and he goes yeah you're having a big one
we gotta get you upstairs as quickly as
possible because it's what i think it is
we got to move fast
so i didn't even know i was having a
heart attack so it wasn't painful
how it manifested with me is i couldn't
quite catch my breath so if you've ever
had the feeling of like
can't catch my breath like ran too far
or whatever and [ __ ] and you're panting
that's what how it felt to me uh my
particular heart attack
so scary because it wasn't painful we
you know associate pain with like
if you're in pain you try to get help
right away i wasn't in pain so i wasn't
gonna try to get help
so if you're gonna have a heart attack i
have one of them painful ones man that
make you go ow
cause then people listen uh digitard
says
kevin i went to the phoenix reboot road
show thank you and kevin and affleck's
team with logan
hit me in the fields as a parent it was
designed to do so
and that kid was wonderful in it and
let's be honest ben was
about as amazing as he could ever been
in that scene he was perfection
when it finally got put together what
was your thoughts seeing it edited and
muse eliciting
that reaction um i loved it it's one of
my favorite
moments in anything i've ever been
involved with in my life like not just
movies but like
including the birth of my child and
stuff just a really wonderful
human scene and then behind the scenes
how it came together because i hadn't
spoken to ben in like 10 years
that was beautiful as well so like on
camera there was beauty behind the
camera there was beauty and stuff and
you know that's what art's about
supposed to inspire art's supposed to be
beautiful you know even ugly art
supposed to be
beautiful in an ugly way and stuff
beautiful in as much as it wouldn't
exist where
that expression wouldn't exist that had
the artist not chosen to make it and
stuff
bringing beauty into the world so
terms of that highlight of artistic
achievement i'm
as far as i'm concerned in my career man
and that's not because i'm a brilliant
artist
is because i had all the right pieces to
play with he's [ __ ] wonderful in the
scene
his daughter is wonderful in the scene
joey is great and see my sister virginia
plays joey's partner in the scene she's
great
and ben is just sublime absolutely
sublime
like i wrote that that monologue for him
and i had worked with him in like 12
years since clerks 2.
so you know i was writing to an old
version of ben and well i used to talk
like this and he used to be able to do
this
but i fully expected that he would just
change it put it in his own words you
know he's a director
[ __ ] now at this point so it's not
like i still could be like well
i know what's going on here and stuff i
fully expected him to just do whatever
he wanted but he honored the words
and gave a performance reminiscent
of the performance he gave in [ __ ]
1996 when we made chasing amy
like you got to understand that dude's
been a lot through a lot in life
professionally personally and [ __ ] he's
lived an epic [ __ ] life
and done a lot of a lot of movies since
chasing amy i've done
like nine or ten movies since chasing
amy ben has done
double that if not triple that right so
you'd imagine
there might be a disconnect but instead
he was right there
came right back to the [ __ ] moment
that we were making the movie years ago
so it made it such a special scene man
like you know
i i have a hard time understanding if
people don't like that movie anyway
i allow it i'm not like you know how
could they not but i'm like what that
movie's so warm and wonderful and stuff
but that scene particularly is like you
could probably [ __ ] on the rest of the
movie but that scene is just
absolutely wonderful um you know if i if
i
had to submit a scene for like the
lifetime achievement oscar
over the course of my entire existence
thus far it would probably be
that scene um it just works really
really well um
and that and again it's not because i'm
very good it's because i had
the talent to back up the ambition in
that scene
oh and the history and stuff there's a
lot going for that scene
um all right man uh what
i pio3 says what will it take for the
two of you
to do an intro for my media assignment
let's do that [ __ ] right now
give us your name uh uh
ipi03 i'll scroll down so hopefully we
see
and tell us the exact give us a little
script tell us what you want to say
this is like a free cameo right here
um go ahead i'm waiting for you
uh meantime let's see
kevin i saw you posing with hassie
harrison from tacoma fd
you have something to do with that show
i don't but i do know the
the boys from um
broken lizard and i believe the tacoma
fd show
is the boys from broken lizard and from
uh was the movie everybody knows
um
about like is it kevin heffernan you're
talking about because i have a picture
uh with me with a few of the folks from
broken lizard because years ago my
friend brian lynch
made a wonderful funny movie called big
helium dog which all of the broken
lizard cats even jay
chandurkasar the director he was in it
as an actor and stuff
and hopefully we're going to release
that movie this year in 2021 we've been
sitting on it since 1995.
don't feel bad for brian lynch he has
made the minions movie um he made the
secret life of pets
uh he became a huge writer but um years
ago
we made this little comedy sketch comedy
movie called big healing dog he did he
was the director
and um that's where i met all the kevin
heffernan and um what's his name um
michael ian black and uh jay and a bunch
of other cats and stuff
so that maybe that's what the picture's
from it would be from like 1995-96 at
that point
um okay all right so we wanted the
script from
where is it i pi pi i
pi or whatever where was it yeah we had
to scroll down more
until the chat catches up oh you tell me
when it's caught up
uh right oh so when you get to a certain
point it jumps back
up it's crazy yeah it's like right when
you get down to like right there
start going super slow like like
play-doh potato
bike baloney everyone is breathing
deeper right now
um met kev here jay's in charge now
jay's driving
let me tell you something if you were
ever in a car you want jay driving he's
one of the best drivers in the world but
i don't mean driver like he's safe
he's reckless but you'll never die he's
real good at handling a car it's like
driving with a stuntman
i like to pride myself in the same kind
of way i think i'm a very good driver
not good meaning i adhere to the laws
and the speed limits
but good and as much as like i get fast
i get places fast and i don't
get in accidents i guess that's not the
standard for what a good driver
is um i so badly want to give this
person what they want
but what does breathing deep mean
no no no here we go now it's caught up
on all right so we're caught up so we're
looking for
ipy or they maybe they took off right
maybe they're like i'm [ __ ] done with
this
i'm done with this you don't do [ __ ] hey
man happy to report that our boy brendo
man
is uh yeah alive and well uh a couple
days ago on social media we put out a
friend of ours missing thing uh like
have you seen brendo
and uh brendo was seen made himself seen
and brendo doing good man brendo with us
so thank you for everyone who passed
that along and stuff
he's such a sweet guy um okay
i don't see him yeah i guess they [ __ ]
off
hey kevin met you in proven providence
reboot show
had a great night missed you jay by the
way i had movie burgers shipped to
nantucket awesome thanks for everything
brian and christy
thanks kids that's right if you want a
movies meal kit kids go to
moviespopup.com
they asked me to be in letter kenny and
i couldn't get on a [ __ ] plane to get
there because i'd had a heart attack not
too long before
and the doctor was like you're too it's
too soon for you to get on a plane so i
was gonna be in an opening scene i think
of the
last season of letter kenny and i missed
it man and i
[ __ ] love that show i worship at the
altar of that show it's so [ __ ] smart
um so funny and right up my alley it's
almost when i watched it for the first
time i was like
i swear to god somebody made this
exactly for me for an audience of
one maybe two me and scott mosher but
it's i'm
so glad to see that like because of hulu
it looks like a lot of people have
discovered it now
so i would love to if they ever give us
another opportunity man
i would love to be on letter kenny so
his name's kyle
write it again if you can ipod because
the chat was moving and kevin
there is there is ipai kyle
kyle sale but it's assignment about us
it'll come back he's gonna thank you so
much everyone
come on ipod coming up yeah do it again
i write it again so it's fresh in the
bottom
uh is this i said say hey man you're
watching kyle
sells media assignment about me kevin
smith is that the line eye pie is that
what we're looking for
yeah perfect real quick riversong 86
says why don't you like the host from
hot ones
oh that's not true i just the the host
from hot ones i don't think likes us i
think it's vice versa
um but no i don't i've never said i
don't like
sh it's sean um
let me see can't wait for mass of the
universe
i'm with you on that it is [ __ ]
phenomenal uh
kevin your panel says digital for bill
and ted finally got me super excited for
the movie i mean let's be honest you
cried everything very true
but your enthusiasm and comments and
being honest and endearing sold me two
more weeks telling you man and the way
they're releasing it
like for home release there's no way it
doesn't work
you know if you had to go out to a
theater some people might
[ __ ] like that wasn't the experience i
thought i was going to have or something
like that
but watching this at home everyone's
going to have the experience they were
hoping to have it's beautiful
beautiful movie they did they stuck the
landing that's i don't know how else to
say it man it's they they did it
um night wolf says can't wait for masses
of the universe
thank you and then where was the uh
remember they just put it on the thing
oh here we go
hey man you're watching kyle sells media
assignment about me
kevin smith and then you jump in and say
and me jason muse all right cool so you
could always cut that
ready so we're looking at the camera
kyle
hey man it's me kevin smith and you are
watching kyle sells media assignment
about me
kevin smith and jason muse me well not
so much him but definitely me
kevin smith go get him kyle
we did thumbs and point at the same time
look at that we made somebody happy man
thank you action man for subscribing bro
hugh
hugo j heredia says no announcement of a
new batman comic by kevin smith at dc
fandom
i'm not going to the fandom i'm i wasn't
invited
um mark bernardin's going to the fandom
but i wasn't invited inside the fandom
i'll be watching fandom outside with
everybody else man
i can't wait man they're gonna see this
we're gonna see the zack snyder's
justice league trailer
um might be that matt reeves shows us a
little bit of batman as well
i don't need to be involved i just need
to let them let let them
let me watch it that's what i want uh
super
super huiso says is movies coming to
canada
stand by that's what i could say right
now um
kev when are you going to make your own
twitch channel i
technically i think i have one somewhere
but i honestly i've said it before and
i'll say it again any time i come here
i love coming to jay's studio to do it
like it's fun to come here and do the
twitch here and and
i love when the hype train happens i
keep saying it's like vegas so many
bells and whistles and
lights and it's fun and [ __ ] like that
kevin michaela says if you're ever in
vegas again
would love for you to come oh man it's
growing
where's the tiki bar uh to come to the
tiki bar and we will make you some
amazing vegan food
done and done uh what is your favorite
dish besides beyond meat i was just
gonna say beyond burger
my boyfriend is a guru of taking any
dish and making it vegan
all right so what is my favorite dish in
the world chicken pieces
that's yours no what's this chicken
strips you eat those are good for me
what chicken i don't know
veggie grill yes the uh the uh buffalo
wings
oh yeah i do like those um i believe me
next time in vegas
probably be a red hot minute but i will
go to tiki bar man
now we'll look for some of that vegan
food thank you michaela
um yeah but anyway i love coming to his
twitch channel i'm glad he's got
this going on and whatnot and thank you
everybody for coming out and supporting
the boy
as he builds his own media empire it's
like a
modern day sumner redstone modern-day
rupert murdoch but you know nicer and
less political
that's who jason muse is um and you're
all smart
to hang out here on his twitch channel
because you could always walk away with
some
cbd hemp yeah
yeah isn't that nice the good folks at
caviar make
hemp if you live in a non you know
weed legal state but you're like i want
to be in on the jay and solomon bob
smoking magic i want my berserker
you can get just the hemp cbd version
and the oils i gave away
i got a nice box i'm walking out of here
with
many thanks everybody i'm going to give
jay back a show
um i had a good time we had this rocking
of like eight thousand people at one
point
it went up when you right when you walk
out there because this takes time that
uh went up to 10. it was a 10 000 five
baby
that's right we hit ten thousand we rang
a bell [ __ ] the hype train
level five we got to ten thousand no is
that right
yeah ten thousand thousand people
oh my god saying hello if every one of
them click
on you know my youtube uh sun and
lockdown video
right now i win i will win celebrity
show off go to youtube
right yeah it's just me tori spelling
and
jason mraz so let me look let me look at
the
look at the standings right here
uh i'll tell you where we are oh man
look at that old what's in the box oh
you guys 36 40 whatever however many
people are on right now
don't forget go to kevin uh the
celebrity show off
here we go right now yeah just go to the
tbs
uh youtube channel and click on my
celebrity show off kevin smith's on
lockdown episode nine
right now we're up to 8.6 k
views tori is catching up
with 7.8 k views she's only 800 000
views behind me that means she could
take the lead i need all the clicks i
can get
guys jason mraz is uh 3.1
uh k views so yeah man if you want to
help
uh deliver me uh from evil
uh oh no not evil if you want to put me
into the top spot and stuff
you go to uh tbs
uh youtube page man and there's kev
right at the top there
um and click on uh i'm sure somebody
will put the
the link in the description
but yeah guys click on help them out get
it done if
even happy you guys that's still that's
another almost 2
000 people clicking don't go away just
open a new screen
oh [ __ ] thank you bona nista bonanista
showed up in a big bad way look at all
these
look at all these gifted tier one subs
bonanissa what are you doing
70 of them holy [ __ ] thank you much i'll
have a talk with you
there's too many that's too much for him
he's going to be spoiled
how am i supposed to give him gifts
after that i gave him a birthday gift he
was just like
i want tier 1 subs you [ __ ] and i was
like i don't even know what that is
that's going back a long time
i'm gonna catch up it's so quick put the
link in the chat yeah
founder or zany can you try to work that
out for me
zaniak if you can put that link in there
for me for kevin
10 minutes later yeah sorry because they
clicked but
bonanista celebrity show off son of
lockdown
episode nine maybe you can't put it in
well they can't well they can't if
they're not mods because otherwise
people can just post
put links galore oh so you need a mod to
put it up yeah can you guys do that
uh so what is that one
sad kian who said how are the cbd
gummies
i i can't take them because they're got
gelatin in them and i'm vegan
however jason lee like i gave him a
bottle
he liked him so much he like texted me
three days later he's like can you send
me more of them cbd gummies they really
work
so according to him [ __ ] he's on
board man he loved him
and caviar they don't make a bad problem
caviar
kevin do you game i don't i don't got
game
as they say uh the cult crow 007
i'm i'm working on a mall brawl right
now
on my new nintendo switch yes
but uh first person games terrify me
like uh they're too fast and and new
and 21st century and i'm still a
scroller i'm a side-scroller man
so uh yeah i i do game but on a very low
level
i don't i don't got game um found to be
missing but looks like put the
thank you there's that link man there's
the link guys click on it please and get
kevin up there make him jump
up to the first place keep him in first
place um
that looked like something interesting
to read hold on
morty your buddy morty said cbd isn't
just
for non-legal states my what good point
i was going like we could send this to
non-legal states but
morty's gonna tell us the story my wife
only ever had a few hits
a week of thc weed because she loves
smoking
but doesn't like getting high often what
since we found cbd buds for her
she smokes more of that than i do th
seaweed
and she's been able to stop taking both
pain pills look at that [ __ ] the local
small town dispensaries don't always
have it
but we try to keep her stocked up that's
good to know so cbd has
some good effects for some people morty
make sure uh morty
for sharing that story write me and i'll
give you i'll give you a jar baby
we'll send you some cbd buds some fat cb
but they come in a nice box
with our picture on it only if you give
me 10 000
subs though bonanista said bonanista
gave you a bunch of subs and asked for
only one thing
oh show kevin baldwin what is it
oh my god how do you show me okay
thank you oh yeah thank you bona nista
all right here we go
my local shop has been out of cbd oil
for weeks
can your brand be shipped to manitoba
says saucy studios mb
i believe uh it sells in canada if i
remember correctly
may not have the fancy packaging because
you know they they're kind of
they keep it bland there all right now i
just gotta change it
oh i've i saw pictures of this on uh
twitter this is fall guys
now what is it exactly so you just you
you uh oh i feel so
hip my fingers are little you gotta run
across
it's literally an obstacle course error
fail to log in
please check your connection uh-oh are
we not connected
you gotta get yourself connected
writing's on the wall
another error dude how am i supposed to
see this
if there are all these errors happening
[Music]
ruby mr drizzle says would you like a
chocolate covered pretzel i would
actually
pop up arts papa says jason lee needs to
stress relief from alvin
wow van that's right he's like give me
them cbds
tired of dealing with this ornery
chipmunk
who by the way was played by justin long
guys i wonder if the servers are down
there's no way
we uh the [ __ ]
we're still alive because there's yes i
mean so it's not my internet that's why
it could be the servers wranglers
servers are down they just said it
ah wrangler dave says you two are savage
as [ __ ]
thank you [ __ ] you don't get to
watch fall guys because servers are down
sorry guys well that's a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] i
wanted this i'll see it next time
i was not expecting this level of
wholesomeness says enigma 77-67
you guys have been an inspiration for me
for a long time i don't even smoke cbd
oh man i hate when that
scrolls up and you're in the middle of
it how do you go over there
oh now i'm free you know all the tricks
um you guys have been an inspiration for
me for a long time i don't even smoke
cbd weed not legal here but i appreciate
the hell out of this um
that's so sweet man thank you enigma
um all right should i turn you back to
your regularly scheduled program
already in progress yeah i was gonna
show you
where does one get a buddy jesus face
mask
if you go to amazon and enter jane salam
bob there is an
entire jay in silent bob store at amazon
uh
in amazon us in amazon uk
and in amazon germany soon to be won in
amazon canada
amazon.cma
or you could always go to jane silentbob
secret session but i don't think they
have any masks there that's what they
were asking about specifically
we'll make sure that happens that's
right you can always go to jsonbob.com
ladies and gentlemen
um or go to amazon and i'm telling you
there's the jane's home bob page is
impressive you could get
any of the logos like put on anything
man like even if you were like
i opened my wine and i thrown out the
cork i need to stick a [ __ ] cork in
this
they have like a jane bob [ __ ] wine
bottle topper so
if you like james alan bob you can get
them put on anything um
there it is uh sl extra says the reboot
was [ __ ] masterpiece thank you
you answered so much and had every
thinkable reference so well done
that means world to me thank you so much
treymok says kev i ordered
preorder level 52 statue if i mail it to
jay will you guys sign it for me
absolutely what i would suggest is don't
send the whole sculpture
send a base or the back wall or
something and we'll totally tag it up
man but that sculpture is
[ __ ] amazing have you seen it yet no
level 52 remember when we got scanned
for the sculptures yeah
they scanned our faces real well they
it's available they put it out for sale
there's only 500 units man and it's
[ __ ] gorgeous
sideshow bought a bunch yeah pull it up
sideshow bought a bunch man so uh
people will be able to to get them but
treymark was smart to get his
man what am i typing
level level 52
studios home clicking on can they see
what we see
social media maybe i click on their
instagram
oh there's the statue
yeah look at that bro
let me give you a better picture yeah
and if you go to if you hit that
x it'll pop full screen i mean not that
square
yeah so now it's full screen and then
over there for them
um here you go
it's got a little video you can watch
level 52 studios.com is where you want
to go
they do really nice work hold on that's
not even the full
what are you waiting for man go order it
right now go to level52studios.com and
order your
json
level52studios.com is where you want to
go
where's the other video
they're talking about doing a black and
white edition
um there's there's one video that just
like [ __ ] plays man and it really
there that's kind of nice
look at that beauty egg can you make it
bigger no that's better
no yeah that's impressive man they did a
really nice job
good congratulations and thank you nice
traymon to the folks at level 50. yeah
thank you for buying it traymon um
you're a wise man i'd say oh here's
three minutes and 42 seconds so here
i've been
chasing kevin smith um
other than the word
you know
merchandise for my movies i didn't think
clerks or
or mall rats changing i didn't think any
of those enough of this [ __ ] guy
he's talking so much and then one day
i love it
of jay and silent bob can you believe
this
look at this look at how beautiful it is
look at the sexy
shots right look at that
angle they got more shots than this than
a standard kevin smith movie
just a pro height a sculpture this
gorgeous
[ __ ] it looks like a little
music
have you ever wanted to own a miniature
version of james on bob yeah yeah
realistic likenesses look at our eyes
look at it every day on a shelf maybe
you can take off the sculpture put in
your pocket
now's your chance the good folks at
level 52 studios urge you to go to level
52studios.com
thank you there's only 500 of these
polly stone babies gonna be in existence
it's
limited worldwide ladies and
um how much does it cost like all fine
art
it's gonna cost you a little bit man uh
it's like 349.99
but you ain't never owned a sculpture
like this
yeah sculpture like how much you think
that you'll be like 349.99 i was like
you need help
because now i own james bob
they make me happy don't have some
people put up a crucifix
this is my crucifix in fact that's how
we're selling it from now on
you want to own the most metal crucifix
ever
that looks nice good job trey mark well
done for buying them and bonista thank
you bro for all those gifted subs dude
you got
more those are wonderful gifted subs
thanks everybody for
hanging out with us are you sticking
around yes sir
i am never leaving so he'll be here
but i'm out of here i'm gonna take my
gifts and get out of here man
thank you for this box uh kids
i give you the one the only
the little snooch uh the little sonic
boom
with dirt on it master gamer and
masturbator
jason muse thank you guys thank you guys
thank you i'm gonna say oh guys i'll be
right back i'm gonna go say goodbye
to kev i'm going to play a little
something for you guys like i always do
hold on here uh i'm going to play this
i'm going to put on
uh yes
where is it we're going to get it we're
going to get it on
where's my oh where's my music on there
we go so let's play this
newest one here